okay
um you touched upon this too but I think
it deserves a little bit more attention
Putin is a master psychologist and he
has carried out what I call an elaborate
Psy Ops operation to convince the West
that he's willing to use nuclear weapons
over Ukraine
as you made public yesterday he
threatened you personally in a phone
call with with missiles
even though he has made this threat
numerous times whether it's guards
Finland and Sweden joining NATO whether
it regards Ukrainian military operations
and Russian declared territory in four
obelis in eastern Ukraine and not
carried through people still take this
seriously your thoughts on this well so
I just I just repeat what I what I I
really don't think we should get sucked
into his his narrative he wants to frame
this as a confrontation between
nuclear-arm NATO and nuclear arm Putin
and he want that's how he wants us to
think about it and he's you know he's
he's like the fat boy in Dickens he
wants to make our flesh creep uh he
wants to he wants to Spook us uh that's
that that's what he was up to in that
focal you know we mustn't it's a rabbit
hole this is a much much simpler problem
this is about and I I he won't I believe
use nuclear weapons I think it's
vanishingly unlikely for the reasons
four or five reasons I I gave in my in
my opening uh remarks the the impact in
China the impact on the swing voters
around the world the catastrophic
Economic Consequences uh for for Russia
uh the uh the apprehensions of the
Russian people themselves and the the
Strategic fact that actually uh the
ukrainians will probably fight on and
win anyway so look I don't I don't think
that that's uh gonna happen focus focus
focus on on Ukraine and getting them the
stuff they need okay some people in the
west are now calling for ceasefire in
place others say that such a ceasefire
would simply enable Putin to rebuild his
army and then come back for the rest of
Ukraine your thoughts on this
um I I agree with the second group